somebody who i am always thrilled to
call a friend and a longtime colleague
nobody better than this man a legend
hall of fame sportscaster courtesy of
nutrasystem chris berman how are you
chris nice to see you rich good to be
with you home game you and the rams a
home game yes uh nice job we try to
install the oculus here but it was not
uh it's apparently safe
motion
stepped in osha stepped in
not safe
thank goodness for them but
but they're always there red tape a lot
of red tape couldn't fight through it
but yeah you're right home game
yeah you the box rams rich
[Laughter]
i hope to hoist a trophy yeah absolutely
anything's possible you look great how
much weight have you lost um
well you know i i was at the nose tackle
okay unfortunately right and now i'm
kind of a big hitting outside linebacker
scat back punt returner okay i don't
think you can drop into coverage
in a year and a half
i mean not to get but sure a lot of it
was done last year when i was turning 65
well now a year and a half ago like
let's lose 35 right about 10 or 12 more
this year just
and you get started kind of after the
super bowl you know new year's
resolution but we're doing football
right yeah we have football we have
something to eat
well after the super bowl is a good time
to get to go so
hey look
66 going gonna be 67 in in may
you can't be
the key is
i put in a suitcase when i lost the 35 a
year ago again i don't want to go on it
i mean but look
and i picked up the suitcase i went
you've been carrying that around hmm
yeah what a
yeah jerk i i said another word you know
are you an idiot right you pick up 35
pound suitcase or 46 even like you're
carrying it around i'm not saying you
are no so right and these all these
jackets and stuff that i really liked
yeah you can wear them again there you
go
speaking of saving budgets you know like
by having a home super bowl right that's
right just take them in a little and
then they look good right so so thanks
for your six huh ten more you could have
matched the super bowl number you know
what i mean
goals or goals next year super bowl 57
right you lose 11 more either or work
for heinz
i like that
chris root 66 berman
i'm trying uh by uh so if you can do it
as well uh nutrisystem uh chris berman
is here on the rich eisen show again
we're here on nbc sports on peacock nbc
sports audio and our terrestrial radio
audience is back here for our super bowl
56 show uh the rich eisen show um here
in los angeles california
our friends at uh netsuite by oracle is
a sponsor of the rich eisen show ready
to upgrade go to netsuite.com rich chris
berman is here on the program um and it
is like i said it's always great to see
you man so it's a super bowl rich you
know it's not the super bowl necessarily
we all saw coming but that this season
was a season that was
different not
they're all different yeah right but
if you if you think about it no dominant
tim and you know you've talked at ad
nauseam with what what you do here what
you do in nfl network and i can't
believe you've been away from us for the
espn for almost 20 years that's uh
you and stu god rest his soul god's word
i think of the young ones
and you were i'll say it again you were
so gracious i was 26 when i walked in
there from market one
you know whatever the heck it was in
redding california
and um i remember i'll say this with you
sitting here i don't know
i apologize for embarrassing you if i
yeah okay
no no i i just remember
when i first started there
it was uh a probationary period where i
was just observing
yeah there was no espn news yet they
didn't
pass me you know
they used to run everything past me well
but those days are over but i just
remember i was i was observing so what i
would do is i'd sit in a room with watch
the sports center ideas meeting go down
and one of the first sports centers it
was right around um late mid to late
february of 96 it was when you would
come back in for a handful of shows
because you were doing it
football's over so you did some sports
centers and i remember you walking into
the room for the ideas meeting and the
guy that i was watching on television
walked in the door there wasn't a single
affectation there wasn't a single
thing about you that wasn't the guy that
i thought i had already known
and i thought to myself this i i took it
in and i'm like this is
a mark of success but also something
that i want to take away that it's
there's going to be no filter it's going
to be me because i saw that from you
and um
so i just wanted to say that so thank
you you know you are most welcome i i
honestly i saw that and i thought to
myself i got to do that well you know
so i think some the only thing i would
take from that is thanks but to all
younger aspiring folks to get to where
you are or i me i'm you know i'm halfway
out but i mean i'm i'm
semi emeritus semi retired i'm loving
what i'm doing prime time after the game
i still get up for it i think that's
what my 40th super bowl i don't know
somebody said my 40th am i that old at
any rate back to that
especially if you're on every day you're
not just on
like a weekend show or something yeah
we're not smart enough to be good actors
or actresses
maybe we think we are so you might as
well be yourself right and if that's not
good enough in the long run
then you're not good enough and
if you're not yourself and you're trying
to fool look we all it's a professional
job so there's certain things we we say
in life that we don't say on the air
hopefully not right
but right there should be a stop sign
but sometimes we all run one every now
and then but but um
40 you know whatever years
my point is
people will see through it
eventually and not really him or her
might as well be you right and and
it's worked out and welcome
and and
you know the the whole crew that i i
parachuted into in 96 great crew but
honestly like because it's this same
thing from dan and keith stewart
and robin roberts and bob lee and
charlie steiner those were the people
who were doing the six o'clock eastern
sports center and the 11 o'clock sports
center mostly and you know um so many uh
people who i got to work with it was
unbelievable
just back in that day when the show
ended get ready for the next one
yeah he was still in the 90s and 2000
well i remember
when i was doing one of my first sports
centers i did was a sunday um in march
and you were getting ready to do
baseball tonight you know and then the
next day i would do i
i did uh deuce raps on espn2
deuce wraps for for uh the uh hockey
intermission and billy pedo is getting
ready to do uh nhs tonight the judge
you know and and so you know and i do
remember that you know robin roberts
would do
another game on uh on
prime time and then uh bill pedo took
that chair and i remember you did it too
right stu did it too and it would always
be you know not maybe the the highlight
of the day game maybe not the marquee
matchup of the game and i remember that
that of the day then you came down on
nhl tonight for pedo and you did the not
marquee matchup hockey night like you
thought of that for a long time
i had the whalers against somebody right
obviously
yeah yes
turn around was fair play it was like
they weren't even in line for the eighth
and final playoff spot these two teams
and you did the highlights
ottawa i remember i was there and i
thought it was the most hilarious thing
but here's the thing the more you can do
the longer they keep you around
can you long snap yeah
are you lefty can you get a batter out
yeah you're in that's it okay i know i'm
kidding you are no no you but you're
also not wrong chris berman here on the
rich eisens show so what was you what
was the first super bowl you you covered
niners first one bengals oddly enough so
niners bengals
pontiac which was like 20 below or
whatever it was right
that was my first and now we had only
been on rich fall of 79 so this was the
81 season both of these teams now these
these bengals came out of nowhere like
those bengals oddly enough it's funny
that you you bring that they were six
and ten
the niners were six and ten the year
before two so that was a super bowl
nobody saw coming either right uh joe
montana yeah we heard of him from notre
dame he's okay right and and bill walsh
yeah he's
52 he's
silver-haired could be nothing except
paul brown yeah but okay and
and so these teams are right so that was
my first one
and because
i did the the late
show with tommy
minnie the late great tommy mees uh
often
um i was on a 2 30 in the morning
eastern 11 30 west coast yeah
i picked the niners as the swami almost
every week and the bengals too
and so it was like my best percentage of
all time i've only done the swami 40
because it was like you're like mourinho
you came out of the game i'm on both of
them they kept winning they kept being
underdogs and i have three other picks
if i could just go
50 on those other three and go
you know
two and oh every at any rate and so the
niners
it was i was very tight with them
by accident
i went out to cover the championship
game i know i'm going on and i don't
know how much time we got but this is my
first super bowl i hadn't thought of
this one
i don't know who's watching us we're
only two years old i'm on at 2 30 in the
morning i'm picking the 49ers so what
right this is not like now there's no
i go out to their training it friday 11
players line up for an interview
either randy cross or charlie young
veteran tight end randy great guard yeah
uh
um
later center um
but guard really they said you're the
swami
you've been picking us every week i said
um
yeah i guess i have we have plenty of
time for you because it was a different
world there weren't 9 000 people looking
for interviews and were you surprised
that they had actually heard this yeah
right that's my point
and now here's the catch of course which
we've seen a million times and and and
of all those guys joe and dwight or you
know
dwight we lost a couple years ago to als
and dwight clark and um he became my
best friend but
but
and i'm very cl became close with the
owner eddie de bartolo espn we had seats
like in the in the phone booth in the
press box he goes well you can watch the
game with me
super bowl owner that didn't mean i was
rooting against the bengals because the
bengals were another
wonderful story with kenny and so
here's the bengals
in another super bowl and that was my
first one of course the niners that was
the start of of their run so it was kind
of
in retrospect rich now i'm putting in
not chris berman but in the football
terms
i don't want to say
football made a left-hand turn
with the 49ers
um
the 70s were you know steelers
raiders
dolphins
and of course dallas was always but
but those were the
offen things changed right and the
niners became out of nowhere a dynasty
so it was kind of the beginning of i
don't want to call it modern football
because we've had several
changes johnny united has brought in
modern football for example if you will
but
it was a pivot for the league and it was
interesting that that happened to be my
my first one and now here the bengals
are in it and so many people thought
when the bengals won the afc
championship game first and the niners
were in the nfc championship game that
that would have to be the matchup
because that was the matchup the only
other two times the bengals made it and
saw joe montana now miners are out and
the
bengals have the kid named joe you know
and that's the focus for so many people
this week and rightfully so cause have
you seen i mean what meteoric rise can
this compare to brady's maybe kurt
warner another one for some kid to make
his bones in college do an incredible
job which neither kurt nor brady really
did although brady did have some uh
great games at michigan
he's he's the number one overall pick
doing it right now for the bengals for
the bengals
that was nicer than the bungles i mean
way back when yes but no i read this and
i don't know if it's true that the only
and he hasn't won the super bowl or the
super bowl mvp yet obviously you know
who knows if he will he could obviously
the only two others that were the
uh college champ and i guess envy but
there was no college game back then but
we're right to joe's right yes maybe it
was this early on in your career or
maybe it's just ever joe namath joe
montana something like that i i read it
i haven't
right and none of them have
were able to add a heisman on top of it
he would be the only one national
champion okay and a super bowl
with a heisman in the case too well
here's the thing
this bengal team and i said it thinking
going into the championship game
thinking that
they probably won't get past the chiefs
and at 21 to 3 we all look like we were
correct right of course
we can get into the bengals story after
that but but um
but i said it reminds me of the 88
buffalo bills another team i was very
close with obviously but the reason i
say that they came from nowhere they
were terrible for a decade
and
they started 4-0 and they were really
good and they ended up losing to the
bengals in the championship game with
boomers bengals
the other boomer messiahs yes david
wells boomer
you know we can debate
how you rank the boomers but
whole question
david wells always ranked himself first
and then we went on but another thing uh
um
george scott the baseball that's another
one uh boomer hits taters um
boy i'm really
uh
in honor of the olympics i'm really
doing this slalom here right you're
running into the catalog
at any rate um
um
those bills lost in the championship
game but then became what they were yeah
contenders every year
and i thought if the bengals get stopped
here they're here though this isn't ooh
they caught lightning in a model and
that no no
because they have more than burro avi we
know that
now what i thought at some point and i
don't think we're going to see it in the
super bowl
does the clock strike 12 and the
carriage become a pumpkin does the
prince become a frog
it's funny
they have so many college players not
only berlin chase
harvard ohio state some offensive
linemen that played in i understand it's
the super bowl or the championship game
right but big time
deals in college whether they were
championship games or big money games
that
no they they're they're going to be okay
here if they lose they lose and of
course what they've done twice is hold
the chiefs at three points twice in the
last
half plus of two games both in january
my problem is i needed a new nickname
for burro because i've gone with january
joe well it's february now okay because
the day they beat the chiefs it was
january second third whatever well let's
let's let's let's drill down on this
because we have gotten many suggestions
uh from our phone callers
so uh
let's run some by you and since you are
the um
the master of the nickname so we though
what some of them that are out there joe
scheisty right because i read that but
that kind of yeah
yeah i know i i can say that on national
title
right
joe bird
yeah but that's right so the one that we
heard that we like a lot is uh is joey
business we kind of like that one
business okay the one
i was well i was just about to get to
you sir
tj jefferson you go you go and tell
chris berman yourself your nickname idea
for joe burrow go ahead tj well chris
berman i was thinking because the man
loves cigars so much and he smoked a lot
of them he could be joe heba joe heber
the fact is if he wins the super bowl he
can beat whatever the hell he wants
see i think
calling him joe heber is not that
you know universal but he would smoke
joe hebers right like now now that is
that the workshop
gasoline
but the cigar but then there's the
little glasses but they were changed the
next game so right it's just it's
fascinating that he's doing it for them
it is the bengals rights
but we have to erase that look they beat
the one they beat the two you you've
recounted they beat the chiefs twice in
a month after like being way behind
sacked nine times in the game the last
guy had a playoff game being sacked nine
times that's impossible what no the last
guy to do it was len dawson in the afl
championship in 66. i know he keeps
getting up he
it's like boogers through on booger
mcfarland through on my who's who's
become a great
tommy 2.0 you know what i mean tommy is
tommy tommy jackson who lives in
cincinnati and oh i got a half an hour
of sales pitch last night on
why the bengals will win how's he doing
great tommy's doing great he's one of
the nicest people nobody might be my
best friend i've ever been around in the
same way that i started this interview
by saying how gracious you were him too
man well he's doing great i'll tell him
a little bit and and he may be listed i
mean who knows but um but since i called
him last night i'm with tommy so
give me the local flavor here i mean we
talk every week but now it's the super
bowl
so i got a half hour campaign stump yeah
which was great right um
anyway boogers said the borough game and
we weren't counting on it on prime time
for him to say it
was
you know he joe he gets knocked down
and he gets up again and i pulled from
the deeper workings
jumbled wumbo like
you did say it so
uh
complete credit for that so here are the
bengals
done the old the old-fashioned way draft
but as a coach told me before we knew
they were going to be this good
well if you finish that low so many
years and you have that many high draft
picks sooner or later you're going to
get most of them right and it wasn't a
knock on them it was
okay right it was like a november
conversation i had with a coach in the
division
and and they did but you know what
they're doing on and that sounds like
i'm bengal because we can go to the rams
too and i know we don't have forever but
um um
we go to the bills and the chiefs and
the niners and all my teams who aren't
there but um
um
this coach also told me in november
it's not about the kicker only who now
has gone on to that's a nickname that
i've seen a lot like like um
shooter mcpherson macpherson
yeah i mean 12 for 12 in the playoffs
well one thing that i guess we can
definitely cross off
one but joe
no one's going to be able to explain if
he gets sacked nine times and they win i
will bring it out one last time
i think about bengals and i'll move on
like little things that we always
figured the bankers would be them
totally penalized they're like the least
it isn't i think like the least yards it
is amazing um
here's what a coach told me special
teams
usually
we have an advantage there we don't
and that wasn't just there's a good
kicker right it was
coverage all that like that was told to
me in november
we don't have that advantage this year
they have whatever they've done they've
so it's like little things that we don't
see right what did this defense do to
hold the chiefs to three points twice i
don't know well this is going to be an
amazing match up super bowl 56 um chris
berman you are the man thank you for
coming on here uh nutrasystem everybody
check it out you've lost forty forty six
six pounds
um
uh i don't can't believe that was a pull
right um
you've lost there it is you've lost doug
plank right there yeah yeah doug plank i
look like i should get hit by doug plank
but uh
we're gonna be on uh prime time after
the game real tv okay classic uh espn
the regular right and
the one couple things i'll say about the
rams we gotta go
they've done it the two different
flavors of ice cream right
one builds draft
one builds
the rams next first round pick will be i
don't know if i'll be alive
i'm not knocking it but i mean you know
george allen paige but
so many big name players here they are
they've delivered matthew stafford's a
wonderful story never complained in
detroit never didn't complain going out
in the door during being in there or
leaving love that
whitworth is a wonderful story with the
two the tackle both bengals and rams
that's right here's the best
so there's hope for you and me and i'll
leave it with this although we were
never this level of player
eric weddle from the beach
how about this leading tackler last week
made that big stop right on third down
yeah
here's where i'm looking at you will
like this okay
if the rams win and i'm picking a field
goal game why wouldn't we the way these
playoffs are going right
actually i'm picking
after that speech rams three but i
if i'm wrong i'm fine with it okay so so
it's kind of the bengals swami ish you
know um
if the if if whittle and the rams win
san diego chargers have won a super bowl
there you go that's my story and i'm
sticking with it so the san diego
charges goal by the way
so the san diego chargers and detroit
lions wouldn't it wouldn't suit yes
yes and that would be all like
and that's very bengal-like
well the charges were always better than
that but they just they disappointed
you're right lions and chargers
and that's what we have with two number
four seeds that's why they that's why
they play the games that's why they play
56 super bowl games the spread is down
to four chris it's down to four yeah no
i know no because it's it's
down to three and a half in some spots
too it won't get to three i don't think
i don't think so either but it it's
it's set up for those last two rounds of
the playoffs now the first round was
terrible
but the seven seas we got rid of them
yeah so um right and so other teams that
played like seven seeds but i'm with you
field goal game i like the ramps too
chris cake christian i think you're the
man thank you for coming on
not at all thank you parking meters
running no no no it's the dion's calling
in a few minutes i'll tell him he said
hello please do you got it hey continued
success man i'm proud of you right thank
that we remember you when i uh means the
world thank you chris berman everybody
get on nutrisystem look like this man
why the hell not uh no no no no no they
should uh chris sperman here on the rich
asset show hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here